- Is it, I mean, was it,
like, intimidating at all?
Like, to work with him or just inspiring?
Was it cool? (laughs)
(audience and Sofia laughs)
- [Kelly] Tell me more. (laughs)
- [Sophia] Hmm.
- [Sofia] Hmm.
- I'm just curious.
- I don't think I was intimidated.
I didn't really have
time to be intimidated.
(Kelly laughing)
And there's always something to learn,
whether your co-star's
famous or not famous,
or legend or not,
I think there's always
something to be learned.
- How about you?
How did you feel?
- I was the exact opposite.
(Kelly and guests laugh)
I was, like, freaking out.
I mean, look at them, like,
I've grown up watching the
both of you, and I tried so...
- I'm not that old.
(everyone laughs)
- [Sofia] (laughing) Yes.
- Like, from a few years ago.
- [Sofia] Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And I tried to play it so cool.
I was like, "Hey Kerry, whazzup?"
Like...
(Charlize and Kerry laugh)
Casual.
- [Kelly] Casual.
- Yeah.
But inside I'm like literally shaking.
And I just remember, like,
the first day on set
I had with you, Kerry,
you touched my face in one of the takes
(Kerry laughs)
and I literally went to my parents,
I was like, "I'm never
washing my face again."
(audience laughs and claps)
(Kerry laughs)
- I love that.
- Oh, that's so cute.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Sofia] Yeah.